you know they say the world is safer  than has ever been in the history of  civilization do you feel safer today  than you did yesterday I know I don't  the world has changed war we're fighting  today  he's a different kind of soldier  we need people with the skills and the  attitude  to take on Forex we don't even know  exist  we need someone who can walk into a  tornado and come out the other side like  it was a damn gentle breeze one in the  back you could have just asked me maybe  something flat for you kick some ass  and try to look dope why are you doing  I could definitely make that work  guns girls global domination  and the cages back  snow sciatica Cappuccio deep not nasty  on Easterling river Elia verbal skills